you got a lot of attention uh for the
fact that you hired an all-female crew
Crews to this day still regardless of
the amount of you know lip service paid
to how much is changing in our industry
they are really white and really male
and um I do think it's changing
incrementally but it it requires
intentionality and a willingness to take
risks which I hate calling them but it
is what one would view as a risk in
hiring someone that might have less
experience yeah and that's what stops
progress from happening you know because
I think that's like any sort of archaic
institution that we're trying to poke
holes in right now is the idea that but
this works but this is what we know we
can't change it because that
everything's going to fall apart it's
like when you change it actually the
opportunities for greatness are so much
bigger